From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
A little opening announcement just as it was running.
Okay, today is Saturday, June 4, 2011. My name is Joe Maneye of the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop and we are here to complete an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We are in Albany, Georgia today. In fact, on the campus Albany State University where these last couple of days has been held the 53th Union of the Southwest Georgia Civil Rights Movement.
And we're very lucky this morning to be with Mr. Charles McDune. Mr. Cooke, thank you so much for sitting down with us. It's going to be a pleasure to talk with you about this history. Thank you.
Well, thank you for having me. Glad to be here.
It's a real pleasure for us. I wonder if you could sketch to begin. Just the basics of your family history because I know you grew up in Ohio.
I was born in Massalon, Ohio, June 23, 1938.
Massalon is a community of about 35, 36,000 people. It's generally known for the production of steel and football players.
They have great high school football teams and have had for years. Paul Brown was from Massalon, Ohio.
And the teams of Paul Brown had were famous in this long tradition.
My father had played for Paul Brown and the Massalon Tigers. My grandfather had played in Massalon for the Massalon Tigers.
The Pro Football Hall fame in Canton is eight miles from Massalon, the big rivalry. There is a Massalon Canton football rivalry that goes back well over 100 years.
So I was born in Massalon. My father worked for Republic Steel.
And the big places in town were the steel meals. Republic Steel and Massalon Steel casting were big.
There's a long history of workers in the steel industry that came from Massalon. I remember Ben Ferris, the president of the United Steel Workers, was from Massalon.
And the General Jacob Coxie and Coxie's army started in Massalon, Ohio. And Coxie, General Coxie, when it's laid the army of the poor, was from Massalon.
So there's this long history of workers in Massalon who worked in the steel meals.
Did you come up in a house where politics and race were matters of a lot of attention?
Yeah, because of all things I just told you, I'm a very active in the union. I grew up playing for local 11, 24, the United Steel Workers.
You grew up playing for steel meals, sponsor union sponsor teams. Everybody worked in the steel meals. My grandfather, my uncles, my father, all worked in the steel meals.
And they were all involved in union activity. The teams we played for, the things that were sponsored the parks we played in, the fields we ran down, were generally things that had been produced by the unions.
And the schools, and...
Tell me about those schools. What was the school and what kind of work up there?
Well, schools were very good. In fact, my sister was one of the first black teachers in the Mass and public schools.
My father was trained to be a teacher. But when he got out of school, there just weren't many if any black teachers in northern schools.
Schools throughout the country were really segregated before the 54 decision were highly segregated when it came to hiring.
But I had never been to a black school until I went south. The schools were highly integrated. You know, you went to...
You can go to class with the kids in your neighborhood. And so I guess it was neighborhood schools.
And so the grade schools were all in neighborhoods. Then there were three junior high schools. And then one high school.
So, quite often, you'd go to school with the same kids I went to the first grade with.
I went through 12 years of schooling and graduated with the same kids I had started from.
What was the approximate portion white and black in Mass and all those guys? Right.
Now, I know what it was just about exactly. When I was growing up, there were 38,000 people in Mass.
And they're roughly 3,500 of that 38,000 were black.
So...
Have you been involved in any, what we might now call civil rights activism or activity, the local and ACP, any before you came south?
Yeah. Sort of. Yeah. And it was really... once you booed, it was like stuff that would take place outside of Mass and generally.
I remember one of my aunt's boyfriends. It was a guy in there in Bobby Greer.
Bob Greer played football for University of Pittsburgh. And when Pitt...
When your Pitt was National Champions and they were going to play in the Orange Bowl.
And the people at the Orange Bowl said they would not play against a team with black players.
And so Pitt... so they said that they played Pitt if Bobby Greer could not play.
And I can remember going from Mass to Pittsburgh, which was about 120 miles away from Mass.
As a child, really to support Bobby Greer. And my parents said, you know, he's one of us and we have to help support him.
Later on, or I guess before I got to high school, James Lawson, who was a advisor to Dr. King.
And I believe was the one who really introduced nonviolence to the American people.
I can remember writing letters of support to him when he was in jail for being a contentious objective.
I was supporting Jim Lawson. Jim Lawson was the minister in my mother's church in St. James' AME Church.
Jim Lawson, my entire life, and read him long before he became prominent in the civil rights struggle.
The relatives Horace Gillem, who was an end and a punter for the Cleveland Browns, was my uncle.
So, because of football, one, and where that was going and how that was being, there were a lot of civil rights issues in football about who could play, where they could play.
And that sort of thing, it sort of brought the outside world into math.
And math was really a town of worker immigrants.
It was an immigrant culture. People came from all over the world to work in the steel mill.
And when we started, one thing that you would take away from the old town.
Okay, one last quick thing. It sounds as if, and before we started the interview, you mentioned, there was a lot of ethnic diversity in Maslan in the white community.
Because all these immigrant groups, and even as a young person coming up, you'd seen that there are fine distinctions between what others might have just seen as whites or white culture.
You already were recognizing all these close distinctions in ethnicity.
Well, yeah, because as I said, we were, Maslan was very much an expression of the American dream.
But people came from different cultures. The majority of the people who made up Maslan were immigrants and the sons and daughters of immigrants from different cultures, from Greece, from Spain, from Yugoslavia, from Czechoslovakia, and from the American South.
And I thought, people who came from the American South were just as much immigrants as the people who came from Czechoslovakia, that they were in a country where they were in a place where they could enjoy the fruits of citizenship for the first time in their lives.
And they could enjoy the fruits of their labor for the first time in their lives.
And they had been the underbelly of the societies that they came from, and they came looking for a better life.
A better life of decent jobs, decent schools, and decent health care for the children.
And we're experiencing these things for the first time in their lives too.
So, if so was very, as I got older, I understood it.
Mass and Ohio was very much the American dream. It was the apple pie and all of that, which in fact, because it was a working community, made up of workers that came from all over the world.
I learned about economics in Mass and things I learned. Plus, I grew up listening to General Coxy. He was still alive.
And when I'd go to the barbershop, General Coxy would be sitting there. And the old men, some old men like my grandfather, who had been a part of Coxy's army of the poor, who had marched in Washington years before.
I had, you know, before I have existed, they had done that. But I learned and got told them appreciation for history by listening to these men who were making history.
And my own family, too, the first black people to be in the hospitals. And the doctors, like my aunts, and my mother, were first black people, had at the hospital, was nurses.
And I remember I said after the Second World War that one of the doctors told her that now she was studying nursing and there were a couple of places for black people in the country to study nursing.
And one was in Chicago, one was in St. Louis, it's called Homagee Phillips, in the Homagee Phillips school nursing. So she had gone way there to study mom.
And Dr. Toadah, that she could now, she could go to nursing school and work and study and get a job there in Madison.
So she was the allowance for the first black nurses in the county and in the city. And as I mentioned before, I learned about economics.
Because I knew in school that, or would be mined in Minnesota and in Saudi iron range, that iron ore would be sent to Maslan to be, the ore would be made into steel.
The steel would be sent to Chicago in Detroit mainly, there would be they made into annals, which would be sold to buy more ore to go to make more steel.
And so it was like that. And I learned, so I learned that when the men were working in Madison, if there was full employment, and there was even overtime, they were making lots more steel that would be stockpile for Detroit.
So there would be a time where there would be really good times where the production of steel would go up. And then there would be after that was done, then there would be layoffs.
So that's how I learned about, without knowing what it was called, supply and demand and all of that sort of thing, that were economic fears.
And I learned that in college, I learned that I learned later in college by seeing the reality of it working when I grew up.
And I remember there would be times of plenty, and then there would be times of scarcity. There would be times where you could buy, everybody had enough money to buy whatever they needed.
And then there would be times where you would have to get handouts from the government in order to survive. You would have to pick up coal, falling off of trains to heat your homes, because there was no money.
Let me ask if I could. I'm sorry. Go ahead. You mentioned college just a moment ago. I'm really interested, and I'm also watching the clock, because I know we have only a fixed amount of time here today. What's the story of how do you look yourself going to stay?
I had to get South Carolina State.
Well, remember I started saying that Madison produced steel and football players. I was one of them, not steel, a football player.
And so I was preparing. I sort of had it in my mind what I was going to do with my life, long before college. My plan was I would play ball, go to Michigan, play ball at Michigan, then go into the pros.
I made a good looking woman, have smart kids, and then make a lot of money, and then retire from pros and times, then buy a used car, a lot of liquor store, whatever they did with their money.
And I was set. That was going to be my life. So I figured I knew by the time I was in ninth grade, what I was going to do, how I was going to live.
And that was my plan for years. But my father sort of put a monkey wrench in there, not intentionally, I didn't think.
But my father felt that we being myself, my sister, my brothers should all go to a historically black college or university for at least one year of a manipulation.
And so I was sent, pardon me, to South Carolina State University in Orangeburg, South Carolina. That's where he had gone to school. And that's where he had graduated from school.
And that taught. But say at the time, he taught in South Carolina, a chemistry teacher. But when I was coming out, when I went to school, they didn't have black teachers in the north at that point.
There was a sort of two-aged store that you could have to go south and you could work. All you could come, you could go south and you could work and you could be a teacher.
All you could go north and you could work and you could be a minor or a steel mill worker. You weren't going to be a teacher. They didn't have black teachers in most northern schools until 54 until the Supreme Court decision of Brown vs. Board of Education.
But he wanted me to go south to see really that there was a professional class of black people who did other things. And there were people who did things other than the traditional black bottles, role models we saw as athletes or the professionals were the black athletes or the black people.
And the general directors or the black preacher that was sort of it, that topped out what you could be. And so he wanted me to go south to experience another group of people, group of black people.
I went to Riven Orchburg, fall of 1959.
Had you been a South before? No. Not one time.
Well, when I first was taken, we drove and we drove from Massline to Orchburg, South Carolina. And I had never been South.
When you go to the Massline to Orchburg, you take Route 21, which starts in Cleveland. Route 21 starts in Cleveland. It ends in view for South Carolina in the ocean.
But if you follow that road, it also goes through Orchburg. So to get to South Carolina, you go get on 21 and ride down South Carolina.
The first place you go after you leave Ohio, the next day, this West Virginia. And Ohio, West Virginia, North Carolina, South Carolina, you there.
It was my first experience that my father was segregation. My father pointed out that you have to do bathroom and all that.
Because once we leave Ohio and we're in West Virginia, we can't use these facilities. So what does that mean? It's bread.
So once we left South Carolina, by the time we got to Bluefield, West Virginia, we were experiencing segregation. There were no places to get food.
My father would packed, my mother packed lunch. And so the further you got away from Massline, the stranger it was. And as we went to Charleston, South Carolina, West Virginia.
And then by the time we got to Bluefield, there's a series of black schools, the way. Bluefield, West Virginia, and then on down into North Carolina and in South Carolina.
And the wondering and the questions weren't my father really wasn't giving me answers about what all this means, how this. And then understand, it didn't give it very much thought until we got to South Carolina.
And there it was so very nice because I was in an area. I had never been to a black school before. I had never been South before. And in Orangebury, one of the first day on campus, I recognized that I saw more.
And I was like 16 years old and there were all these girls, all these pretty little black girls. I thought my father was a brilliant man to send me down there and let me be experienced my culture.
And I asked this and said, I can still hear my mother saying, you like who? That's your cousin, you can't like it. It seemed like I was related to every black girl in Massline. So there was a bit of frustration because there was nobody to date and things like that.
But when I got to Orangebury, I thought I was in heaven. There was thousands, hundreds, that's all more black girls. In one day, and I had seen in my entire life. And I was related to none of them. And that just seemed like life could not be better.
How did you get drawn into the civil rights question?
Well, I got drawn into civil rights, like I said, first got there. I'm a freshman. And I remember, is 1959 when I entered.
And of course there was news on television and everything about the schools being integrated, which started after the 54th decision.
And so the pictures of kids walking through mobs to get into schools in Little Rock, Central High School and all that. So first fell in love with one of the children marching through mob people.
But so I wasn't in like all that keenly. I knew these things were going on, but it wasn't just praying on my mind because I was in paradise for the first time.
And we got to, so I'm there and studying. And in first it was wonderful, just wonderful.
But I hadn't been off the campus. When I was brought to school, I was brought to school and I stayed there and I was studying and stuff.
And but it Thanksgiving of my very first year. I had to, they closed the schools on Thanksgiving.
And you had to go somewhere, but you can stay on campus. So I had four roommates. And one of the roommates, a guy named Charles Gatson, took me home with him for Thanksgiving.
And in home for him was Sumter South Carolina. So we went to Sumter for Thanksgiving. And we went to a party at one point.
And after the party, we were driving back to Gatson's home. And the other young men in the car drank and I did. So I was like the designated driver.
And as we were driving home, the cops pulled the sofa. No big deal. It says, I didn't do anything.
So the cops pulled us over, asked for my license and registration stuff and gave me that. And we're talking.
And so the cops said, where are you from, boy?
I think you got the license and to read. It was from Ohio. Well, I didn't understand that that wasn't quite the way you addressed the local constabulary.
I was like saying, can't you read? I think that must have been it because he was a tad peeved and hit me.
When I said, before he hit me, he said, didn't he never teach you how to say yes sir, no sort of white men up there?
I said, you got to be kidding. Yes sir, no sort of white men. Why did you say I do that? And he hit me.
Now this was before the non-violent civil rights struggle. And I came from a tough steel pound in Maslan.
And where somebody put their hand in your face, you return the favor and kind. So when the cop hit me, I hit him.
And before he hit the ground, I was kicking him and stomping him about the head and then he could show us.
And I was going to beat it. But so as I said in this cop, his roommate, his fellow officer, his partner jumped into the fray.
So it seized two cops in me fighting. And guys in the car sort of not doing anything except quivering in the background.
And as these cops were beating me, I was saying to them, I'm going to get you for this because they weren't helping me, which was an acceptable behavior in my mind.
And the cops beat me bloody, broke my arm, busted my jaw.
And that's where it all began. That afternoon, that evening in some just South Carolina.
Because after the cops beat me and jailed me, I was arrested for the first time in my life. And charged with disturbing the peace and disobeying an officer.
Put in jail, took me to the hospital and got me passed up. And then I went to get on a train to go back to the school.
I went to get on a train, the conductor said, all right, get on back to the baggage car. And it says, you know, what is this baggage car nonsense?
And it seems that on every car, on every train in the South, this is in 1959.
There was one car on the train for black people. The car right behind the engines where the certain dust would come through.
And when that was field, field, you said in the baggage car. I said, no, no, no, sport, not for my little $10,50.
Do I ride with suitcases and mangy dogs? I don't do baggage cars. And there are plenty of seats right here.
And I'm having one of them and set down and was re-arrested for sitting in the white car and violating the laws of segregation.
Got back to the school. And once again, I'm back in jail, six hours after I'm out of jail. I'm back in jail.
Got back to Orangeburg. And there's a garden in Orangeburg called Edistowe, E-D-I-S-T-O. Edistowe.
A garden, beautiful park. But it was between the train station and the campus. And I was hurting from the beating.
So I took a shortcut to get back to the campus and was arrested because it was against the law of black people to be in a public park, except on two days during the week.
And that was one of the days. So I've been arrested for the third time in two days. And that sort of started by the time.
And then one I learned very quickly that how much was off-limits. If something said open to the public, it was closed.
It was closed to black people. And you would be arrested if you would go there. And there were all kinds of ridiculous laws I learned about around that time.
It was against the law to look at a white woman, to look at a white woman in her face. It was a form of assault.
So I learned because I'd cost my father all his money for medical bills and for jail bonds.
So by the time I got home for Christmas, my father was saying, that's it. Forget it. You can come home. You're not going to make it that. You're not going to live.
You're going to be down that long enough. And it takes really experienced black people. And by that time I was saying, that's fine.
If I didn't want to be there anymore. And just, when can I leave?
And it happened that we won't semester. And the semester ended at the end of January. And in February, rather.
February 1, 1964 students from North Carolina, A&T College, black students, sat down at lunch counter and Greensboro, North Carolina.
And that was the first city.
The city took places in other parts of the South. And a group of students came to me and said, Chuck, you've heard what's been happening in Greensboro.
And they said, yes, of course I have. And said, well, we'd like to do that here. My response was, we'll go ahead and do it.
What's they got to do with me? And they asked me to be their spokesman. And because at that time I had a reputation of being unusual.
And I'd speak to white people. I heard somebody say, talk to white people just like this. Tell them to you and me. Just like regular people.
And it doesn't respect them for being white of something. So this is who we should have to be our spokesman.
My response was, no, I don't want to do that. I don't want to be a spokesman. Because in another few weeks, I'll be gone from here.
My father will be back down here to pick me up to take me back to Ohio. And after that, I will never come further south than Columbus for the annual Michigan Ohio State game.
And that's fine with me. I never need to be any further south than that in my life. And that's how it all began.
How did you get from February 1960 to Ryan for the SNF founding conference?
Well, I became the head of what we call the Orangeburg Movement for civic improvement.
I became the student leader for the student protest in Orangeburg.
And we were having sit-ins, we were having weight-ins. We were testing all these things, challenging all these things.
And so I started getting arrested. I remember being arrested in Columbia.
And as we took a petition to the governor, then Governor Hollings for Hollings, to ask that they're not allowed.
Laws against going to public places, libraries, beaches, parks, be struck down.
And when we see Governor Hollings was arrested, because black people were only allowed to be at the Capitol, like between hours of four and six on Sunday.
So you can't do any business in. So I went there 10 o'clock on the Monday and was arrested, put in jail.
Well, that was just one of many. That was a letter group of students to deliver a petition in Orangeburg to the city of DAS that public places be desegregated.
And about 800 of us were arrested. And so while this was going on, got a letter from Dr. King and Southern Christian Leadership Conference that there would be a meeting of students at Shaw University in Rowling, North Carolina
to discuss the student's sit-ins that took place in April 1960. I intended that meeting as a representative of the South Carolina State students.
And we were there discussing the movement and with students from all over the South.
During that meeting, Dr. King felt we should all join SCLC. I disagreed.
Because Dr. King felt if you join, if you use to practice nonviolence, that you should accept nonviolence as a way of life in your life.
I disagreed with that because I said yes, I use nonviolence. And we use nonviolence. But for me, it was strictly attacked.
And personally, I didn't believe it would work. It was attacked that I felt had a short life and wouldn't work.
And my position was when Gandhi tried nonviolence in South Africa, it was beaten, jailed, and run out of the country.
As I said in the United States, nonviolence won't work. Because when Gandhi used in India, the tactic of having people lay down on railroad tracks to protest.
I said, and it worked. But if a group of black people lay down on railroad tracks here in South Carolina, Georgia, Alabama, Mississippi, Texas, Louisiana, any of these southern states a train would run you over a backup to make certain you are dead.
You cannot make a moral appeal in the midst of an amoral society. And I said, it was not immoral. We lived in a society that was amoral. And as such, nonviolence was not going to work.
And so I couldn't, and the people with me could not join Dr. King. And thank you for no thanks. And then, those people said, who think like I do, we'll have a meeting down the hall and talk about it.
And that meeting we had down the hall became the first meeting because it was the genesis of the student nonviolence coordinating committee. It was at that meeting at Shaw and Raleigh, Shaw Campus in April 1960.
Then we went down the hall and talked about forming a new group. And at first we were going to call that group the student coordinating committee. And we were just going to exchange ideas between campuses.
But there were some people in the group who were still greatly believed in nonviolence and the viability of nonviolence and practices of nonviolence.
And we felt they should be a part of the group. And most of those students were from Nashville. And had been taught by Jim Lawson, and knew Jim Lawson. And it was an important person to me.
And so we thought it was a good thing to include nonviolence in our title. And so we created this new group and called it the student nonviolent coordinating committee.
That meeting down the hall in Raleigh, and how the nonviolence, you wanted to bring those nonviolent people in from Nashville, influence by Jim Lawson.
I'm just wondering, I don't know if the answer matters too much, but you had that personal connection to your family to Lawson. And out of that, you think you might have been quite as receptive to that bringing those folks in?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, do. And for several reasons, one, they were very dynamic. They were very smart. They were committed.
Yeah, even if it didn't, they obviously were just like us. I mean, I had no grant. I didn't know where we were going with this thing.
I just knew how we were going to get there. I just knew that I was not going to swear that I would be nonviolent all my life. And that was the initial reaction to why I didn't want to join Dr. King.
Dr. King's organization. Tell me how you got pulled forward. The choices you made coming out of that meeting in the spring of 1960.
Well, okay, coming out of that meeting, the two things were about to happen that summer.
And the, both the Democratic and Republican parties were having their conventions. And as I recall, one of them or both of them were in Los Angeles.
We wanted to make as students, sit in students a statement of to the political parties with the understanding.
I didn't know much about politics, none of us did, but we did know something. And so we were talking about getting a plank in the convention of on civil rights and explaining why we were doing what we were doing.
And hope to get both parties to understand and push for greatest civil rights.
So we then elected somebody, not somebody, elected Marion. Barry is a first chairman to take our concerns to these groups and the conventions that summer.
So, and then later, the next fall, when we started meeting again, SCLC and provided money and office space and material for us to get going.
So, we had to set up an organization. And then as that organization grew and our ideas developed and our philosophy developed.
I guess there was also the development of a, a movement of an organizational personality of who we were and how we thought.
And like I say, it would have accepted, put nonviolence in the title. Or not, if they didn't want it in their fine. My thing was that whatever needs to be done to keep us going, I would do.
You soon have to replace, was it at that fall meeting at Atlanta that you replaced Barry as, Mary Barry as the formal chair of, yeah.
And did Rock Hill then follow in the fall of 60? Can you just describe the Rock Hill?
Well, Rock Hill wasn't important, but plus it was in my state. I mean, by that time I started to see myself as a Carolinian.
A lot of the people that were active and the programs that we were developing was happening very rapidly.
So, we were talking, started looking at things like, how long can we keep going if they just keep arresting us? We cannot get out.
So, we talked about a jail Nobel program and where that was going to be tried out was Rock Hill. And the people who would try it out, who would do it, were going to be snake people.
And snake people even became snake very quickly. And it was the name was the creation of somebody, some reporter, somewhere just taking the letters S and C, C, the initials for the organization and then calling it snake.
So, snake's personality as an organization was going to be sort of structured and determined by what we did.
And so, once we started talking about, well, jail Nobel, Rock Hill, there were some wonderful people up there.
I remember it was Reverend Ivory, who was very involved in Rock Hill. And the head of the NAACP at the time, guy named I.D. Quancy Newman.
And Mr. Newman, his head then NAACP, and they were sort of, they had a strong presence in South Carolina.
But the Rock Hill program specifically was going to be directed at trying out the jail Nobel ideas that we had developed.
Tell me about, and I'm just watching the clock a little bit, I know that we could stop at any of these things and spend the full hour on any of these things easily.
You made a trip with a couple of the core snake folks to Mississippi in 61.
And I'm wondering if you can quickly frame that up and then maybe provide an example of what you really encountered and learned in Mississippi.
Well, by that time, by the time we got to Mississippi, we then had, snake had a personality.
Snake was snake, and we had established our own identity and separateness from those other groups.
So when we went to Mississippi, it wasn't core, it was snake.
The freedom riots had taken place.
And we were then about to be involved in the voter registration.
And so we went to McComb in Southwest Mississippi, basically to register voters.
And because we had started at that time hammering out our programs of voter registration and direct action.
And that's what we were going to do. We were going to have two programs, mostly.
One was going to be direct action, sit-ins, weight-ins, that sort of thing.
And the other was going to be the registering of voters.
Can you explain what you picked McComb?
One, we already had to explain to you also why we did voter registration.
And developing this snake personality, I speak of.
We talked about where we came from as people, as black people.
And how black people stopped in doing things, progressive things, and their interests in favor, by violence.
And we had to understand, agreed that no violence was going to stop us.
And we had determined the voter registration because we wanted to do something that would have a long term effect in a very short period of time.
Because in essence, we had planned the death of the organization in its warning.
When it was created, we said that it's only gone last for a certain period of time, a finite period of time, like five years.
And then we were going to move on.
Now the reason we said five years was two things.
One was the very practical thing that you had to tell your parents something.
Most of us were the first in our families to go to college.
And we were not, as black students, we were just not given the luxury of saying I'm going to find myself.
And when I'm finding myself there, and I have to, my mom would knock me out, knock me out if I claim I'm quitting school to go find myself.
You had to say, I have to do this, this is what I'm going to do.
And I'm not going to do it forever.
There's going to be a period that I'm going to do this for five years.
And when we said that, when we put a number on it, it was in our interest too.
Because once we really got in the talk, we knew we felt we wouldn't be able to last much longer than five years anyhow.
You could burn out, burn up, or dead, that you'd be in five years, you'd be in jail, insane, or incarcerated.
And so we got a little time to do this then, and not to get done.
We chose, looked at the American political structure.
And the power and the Senate and the House, and concluded the power in this country isn't really in the presidency.
The greater power is in the House of Representatives and the Senate.
And these places got power by longevity, by being the heads of committees.
And you got that by being in the House of Representatives, therefore, and they were all held by white men, white Southern men, from the black belt of the South.
Louisiana, the most powerful men in government were in the House and Senate, were from Georgia, Alabama, Mississippi, Texas.
And they all came from these places that had heavy black populations, where black people didn't vote.
And they didn't vote because of disinterest. They didn't vote because of fear quite often.
So we chose the worst places in terms of retaliations against people voting.
And these black belt counties, Mississippi, Georgia, Alabama, South Carolina, Georgia, etc.
And said we would go there.
And if we can get people to register in these places, we can get them to register any place in the world.
And if we can make it work in these places, in this place where I'm sitting right now, in Darity County, in Terrell County, in Baker County, in Southwest Georgia,
in Mississippi, in a mid-county, and Pike County, and Walthall County, in Southwest Mississippi.
So they take, Southwest Mississippi, Georgia, we take the worst places, and all these Southern states,
to take a place that had, was heavily black, for example.
And you find counties were 60, 65 percent black, and nobody was registered.
Not one so.
And these would also be the places where the Stenesis and the Eastlands came from, and the birds and the townmages.
They all came from these heavy black areas, and black people didn't vote.
It said so, it was really a very simple, so amazingly simple sort of plan.
Is this just get people registered to vote in those areas, and you can disrupt the balance of power.
So if you get a place, and one of these black bell counties, where somebody's been there forever like Stennis, and was a very powerful man.
And so you get politician A, and a seat, and you get a new politician running against them, politician B.
And politician B says, I'm going to cut the throat of the first born black child born in the area house.
I'm not saying it was fine. Let's vote him in, because the reality is he won't be able to do that.
He won't be able to just want to have enough time to kill every baby.
And never, never thought of that he would try.
He just won't have time to do it.
Get him in, which would mean if you vote for the worst guy in the world, that's cool.
You get the guy in power out, and this new guy comes in a freshman senator, and has no power.
And if you do that, in enough places, we can change this country, and in a short period of time.
But in order to do that, now these people didn't get where they are by being dumb, they will recognize.
The real threat is our voting, and they will fight hard long to see that that doesn't happen.
So the real battle, the battle ahead, we talked about, is not just to get seats at lunch counters, or to go to beaches and stuff, is to get and use the vote.
Now, black people in the past have been scared off by violence, when they tried to make them.
So we have to pledge among ourselves that violence is a part of the game.
It isn't going to scare us off.
We know it's going to happen, but we have to pledge to each other that when it does happen, whether it be beaten, bombed, or killed,
we will not turn away from what we say we are going to do.
And now we are sure that that was the key.
We accept we knew that we looked at, and said in the United States, it's the most violent country on the face of the earth, has brought, made true the biblical prophecy that there would be war and rumors of war all the days of our lives.
But if it isn't shown here, then the late great J.C. didn't know what he was talking about.
Because they were sure that he'd been around, the late great J.C. there, hung him, he'd gone across too.
And we had to pledge that we knew there was going to be a blood price that had to be paid, and that we were going to pay it.
We would, but change this word, this country also. And that's how we got here.
That's why this whole area, Daudi County, and every county around it was one of the key places that we had to deal with.
Let's pause for just a second.
We've got about five minutes, so final points, thank you, register.
Well, I think the key for our future, as Americans, as Black Americans, is education.
I think that the more we learn, it better equips us to deal with the changes that need to be made.
I was a couple weeks ago, I was at Colby College in Maine.
And Colby has, I see that I was speaking to the Posse group.
The Posse group is Black students, Black and Hispanic students who attend college at Colby in Maine, and that's a Posse group.
It's Harvard, it's one that's brand-backed. It's all these top universities.
I think there's one of the great programs that they are funding.
And one of the things I was saying, I was very impressed that I've been doing perfect speaking and with students for years.
And Colby was the first school I had spoken at outside the South in 45 years, where the audience was all Black American students.
All of the students were Black Americans.
And I was very impressed with that. I mean, I've been identified with my brothers from Africa surely.
But this was the only school and the only time that I had just kids from America who were being educated at some of the finest universities in the country, and taking advantages of that.
I see that President Obama, when he won the Nobel Peace Prize, gave a considerable amount of that money to the Posse program.
Even though Donald Trump says that he bought his way through affirmative action into Columbia and Harvard and these other places, I don't care.
I think the fact that he gave his money to support the Posse program was important.
Because I can only see that as growing and continue to support for the Black universities and colleges in the South to all to be supported.
And so there's a need for more teachers and certainly for more students and education needs to be broad.
I think like in Mississippi, the Mississippi public schools, you have to take a course and pass course and civil rights before you finish college.
I think that's something that you be a part of every state in this country because if we need to look at the education or the miseducation of our children, and I had to come South to even find out about our role in Black history and the history of this country.
And I think that role was unique and that lessons to be learned.
And I think that the soul of the nation will be cleansed, strengthened, and helped by understanding the philosophy of the personality of Stink and civil rights struggle.
And I think there's one, when I go to, you know, this campus, I was talking to a kid yesterday who had never heard of us, knew very little about what it took for him to be in school at this place at this time.
So the miseducation of children has to be corrected.
And I think a part of that correcting will be that it all, the bad, certainly Martin, was in the battle.
But the struggle continues. It is not over. And there are many things that need to be done. And their education, our education, is important in moving the agenda ahead.
I think the work of the children is defensively fun. I'm sorry.
The defense fund is wonderful in what it's doing and should be supported.
And I think that the education moved more support from the private sector to many of these things happening.
I think it's helpful that President Pailin bops around the country. She should learn about this part of America also.
That America is not just symbols of liberty. And freedom is not free. And that there is a constant sort of struggle to make democracy work.
And the way you spread democracy in the rest of the world is to show the rest of the world and ourselves that it is a viable and good philosophy that can help people wherever they come from.
So the immigrants that I knew as a child and a masculine and the American dream that people came here to achieve is still a worthy, viable sort of thing.
And I think the way to keep it moving forward is more and better education. I know the new museum this being put up by the Smithsonian.
I think it's important because there is something that because of the relationship of African people who were brought here to be civilized and Christianized, the relationship to our country and the helping define what how our citizenship works.
It's important. And I've learned that every day I'm thankful for waging the struggle here. And it needs to be continued and have greater support.
Mr. McDoug, I wish we could spend a couple of days together, but this has been a wonderful couple of hours. So thank you very much.
Well, thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.